好 景希燈號
已經連續開出了8顆紅燈
史上的最高紀錄是9顆
這一次能不能創紀錄
還有外資在8月大買
上半年把我們砍爛掉了
現在大買
那能不能一直買到年底呢
這邊來請教憲榮
好 八顆紅燈
當然往好處想
好熱喔 對不對
往壞處想就是
史上也才9顆
那到底要破紀錄嗎
還是有什麼問題
再來的話 外資
已經在8月買了3709億
還有下禮拜一
所以現在是一個單月史高的狀況下
外資買 營收又非常強
以及你還順便看了一下
大戶在做什麼
好的 那第一個
先來看景氣燈號的部分
現在公佈出來
哇 七月份連續八個紅燈
而且這八個紅燈不是說
看到41高點之後就往下掉了
目前都一直還維持在高峰
持續的熱絡之中
那當然最大的動力
就是來自於AI的一個供應鏈
持續的一個發展
所以目前來看
这个动能还在持续当中
尤其下半年会打的
Vera Rubin
以及GP300量产
都还是有机会
这地方继续走高
挑战2021年的
联酒红甚至超越
我觉得几率是蛮高的
要创新记录
对
那当然如果说景气持续热络
我们看到最近
这外资终于开始回头之后呢
台币的部分
第一个先反应
最近已经从之前
一路的边边边边边
扁到32.528之后
最近一口气升回到31.57
升了一块钱的幅度了
那技术面现在是
已经往下是升值
升破了这个地方
月线跟季线大观之外
7月份你看到
这一根升下来
它也过了7月份的一个低点了
所以这个结构上
台币的确目前已经有
这回来的迹象
那当然台币回来
大家第一个想到就是谁
外资开始归对了
好 这张表是不是有点复杂
这张表仔细看
你会发现到关键来了
之前外资都还是一直卖一直卖
卖到这个月翻手买超
之后突然大家算一算
到目前为止
8月还没有结束
下礼拜一还有开盘
已经买了3707亿
这个数字已经是外资史上
单月买超台股的新高
之前最多也才差不多2400亿
那关键来了
再配合着台币现在这地方
开始出现转维生值
转维生值转维生值之后
同样的现在
如果看到台币有边转升
外资也开始翻多大买
过去的经验
你会发现到
有一次在2022年的11月
那时候也是外资本来一路的卖
开始转买了
买了1867亿
11月份单月
台币也开始转升了
结果台股
那一个月当然是收红
但是你发现才刚刚开始
后面从12629
涨到17463
涨了多久
涨了8个月
也就是还有7个月的涨势
涨幅总共是达到38%的幅度
那再来到了过了一年之后
2023年的11月
外资又开始本来是调节到
翻多买了2400亿回来
那台币也开始升值
那一个月收红之后
后面又涨了7个月
总共涨了8个月之后
涨到24416
这一次涨幅达到51%
再来最近一次就是在去年5月份
本来因为川普的关税
外资也开始大卖
但是5月份开始翻多了
台币也开始转升了
台股那一个月开始逆转胜
从17306
川普杀到这地方
17306低点之后翻红上来
后面不要说涨到48000
涨了这地方涨到35000
就已经涨10个月的时间
涨了105%上来
所以我们会看到
当台币右边转升
而且外资也开始翻多大买之后根据过去三次的经验後面來啟動8到10個月的行情漲幅38到105%大多頭好像滿值得期待
所以會不會這次
經過7月股災的洗禮
融資大段頭清掉了一批籌碼之後
現在反而是另外一次的
大多頭的開始
如果說外資的買盤現在歸對
我覺得倒是值得期待
當然如果說比照過去經驗
不要講說105%比較誇張
38%的話
大概這地方就有機會
漲到大概5萬4千多上去
倒是可以來做期待的
好 而且發現外資雖然有買
可是其實買一買
它也是會變賣嘛
但不太影響後續的走勢
好像只要幫忙點火就好了
對 就是推動公市的那一把手
開始推出去之後
股市就這樣
8到10個月的漲幅
你怎麼會想到這張圖的
可能觀眾想截圖了
突然發現這是藏寶圖
仔細研究就會發現
台股有很多奧妙的规律
会不断的循环
只是我们怎么去看到它而已
好 奧妙的规律
那当然我们接下来就观察
那既然外资开始回来了
到底买了哪些股票呢
那这张表我们先讲
怎么去挑出来
除了说是观察到
外资买超过1万张的股票
但是也是看下基本面
所以先统计前7月的营收
年增率有超过35%
那为什么是35%的数字
是因为上市公司
整体的营收年增率就是34.3%
超过平均值
在前段班的
那再来呢
不只是前7月
7月份的营收年增率
还比前7月总共加起来的累计年增来得高
代表说进入到下半年
成长的速度还有在继续增速之中
所以这样的条件挑出来
目前看到
当然买最多发现到在哪里
在记忆体的股票
南亚科利基电华邦电
还有后面有金豪科
裡面沒有列出來
還包括微缸 浴窗
其實外資這個月
主要重點幾乎都是在買記憶體為主
光是南亞科利基店跟滑榜店
都是買超過10萬張以上
但這也可以理解
因為這個地方
這兩天也看到
這個地方基邦科技告訴大家
目前雲端服務平台
明年的資本支出
很有可能七成會被記憶體給吃走
回答也這麼講
對啊 好像記憶體變成標準配備
外資開始大幅度的回補
這個部分當然未來
我覺得還是可以持續的關注下去
那另外還包括像下游的部分
鷹葉達 神達 鴻海 基加華碩
這個部分也都有買超
當然如果說投資朋友說
到底怎麼去選
那當然如果選不出來
最簡單 台積電
為什麼台積電 台積電符合
對啊 台積電其實這個符合
外資算不起來沒有買很多
超過1萬張而已
但是你會去看到
当回答告诉大家
明年营收还会继续成长
70%的时候
最大受惠者是谁
当然就是台积电
根据这台积电
这个第二季财报
跟大家所做的指引
告诉大家
第三季的营收
总营收会达到1.4兆左右
换句话说
就可以推算出来
8、9月份的营收
预估应该至少是突破4800亿
甚至有机会挑战到5000亿
这都有机会
所以8月份、9月份营收
还会有继续创新高的利多
那当然这个动能应该没有问题
那短线上技术面当然就观察
8月19号低点不要破
这个之前刚刚讲过
台积电的一个规律就是
高点拉回大概回挡10到15%
回挡10到15%
涨上去之后这是周线图
你会发现这边
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
14周
这边又是涨个13周
那所以说目前为止
大概涨个5周时间
还有9个礼拜
这个8个礼拜可以继续涨
那8個禮拜大概就是
10月中旬的法說會
這個之前我覺得台積電應該是慢慢漲 慢慢漲我們還是期待它不要要涨太快慢慢涨慢慢涨那台股的一个动能就会继续的往上推上去我觉得还是大家
这个地方长期投资
最主要的首选
那当然如果说不想买那么高价
或是那么大型的股票
低价有没有这地方可以留意
我们看到刚才讲到
这个下游组装的部分
但是我会特别注意神达是
它不只是组装
它还有一个特别的
就是现在在6月份的
电脑展当中
它推出了52U的一个
高密度AI液冷机柜
还有所谓钻石的散热伺服器
换句话说
它也从原本只有这个机柜而已
这个组装而已
开始跨入到散热的领域
这个评价可能就会不一样
然后这个部分
股价目前都还是很闷
但是这种股票我们常常讲
均线越是纠结
常常是不动则以
就是一個比較大幅度的行情
到時可以觀察啦
憲榮都知道我要講什麼
就省達我們再給你一次機會
對 總是要有動的時候
你一直躺著
他一直躺著
其實因為我們有一些達人
也覺得省達很有價值嘛 對不對
他一直躺著
希望你別再躺了
我們已經告訴大家
你有這麼多好處
然後憲榮就說
因為大戶真的蠻愛省達的
你覺得他真的叫敘事待發
好 那當然操作上面
我會不要建議
如果說你有耐心就買來
買一些抱著
如果說覺得這地方
我要比較快的話
可以等哪一天出量長紅一個
比較大的成交量
攻擊產局
那個攻擊力道出來的時候
進場這也是另外一種操作的方式
那除了說這地方外資買盤
開始進場
那當然其實看到前陣子跟他講過
主要這一波大戶外資
都是集中在跟電源相關
或是散熱的部分
光寶科上個禮拜才推薦
今天已經又創歷史新高了
那雙紅之前大家覺得
好像這個都沒跟上
今天跟上來了
1155塊也創了波段新高了
台光電當然是這個長期看好
我們之前提到
這個白紅官日出來開始轉強
現在也已經開始轉強
我覺得這一組來看
目前都還是台北股市的晉升指標
還是有機會繼續帶著上去的
好 雙紅我上次也同樣問過憲榮
我說現在看起來強的是見測期紅
雙紅都叫不動這樣
但是動了
持續送暖總有幾個的
蠻會送暖的
是好
那這個部分當然上來了
我們再來幫一些股票看有沒有機會送暖
那第一個我們先看大戶的部分
一樣400張大戶有在加碼增持
量要夠第三個股價要佔回至十日先之上
代表趨勢上是一個往多
最近看到這地方大戶還是持續在加碼
我們說的電力
包括外部的重電或者是這地方
例如說在BBU 電源這一塊
所以這個部分
像今天松川晶蜜
這是有電源的計電器
那計電器很便宜的東西
但是它壞了
整個電源大概增足就壞了
所以這又不能沒有它
那BBU的部分
最近這地方看到
也都有開始加溫的動作出來
所以先看龍頭指標股新勝利的部分
新勝利也是離前高非常近了
差幾塊錢而已
好 最近股價慢慢的上來了
快要突破前高
重点是技术面上来看
这边月线季线
已经有开始黄金交叉出来
回测完
最近这地方连续三个礼拜
400张大户都有开始这个加码的动作
成交量也开始有在这个地方增稳
所以目前这个结构上来看
是有机会突破前波高点带动上去
我觉得是没有太大问题
尤其这地方营收的部分
进入下半年
BBU的比重在持续拉高之下
现在7月营收又创新高
那今年BBU比重持续提高
我認為這個下半年的成長動能
還是很值得來做期待的
那當然如果說
覺得新增率都快創新高了有沒有這地方基期相對低一點的那最近有一檔股票這個漢權的部分哇 股價是蠻強勢突破了下降壓力線之後一路的一個急噴上來
最近也看到400張大幅有開始回穩
那它最主要做這個
電源裡面的板端連接器
是這個地方包括光寶客
包括台達電板端的連接器
幾乎都是找它來做供應
所以當現在這地方
這個800V帶動板端連接器的需求的時候
看到最近这个光宝科 台达电
据了解都有持续在追单的一个动作
也带动业绩7月份营收
开始创新高上来
所以量能的部分
这个地方急速放量
当然股价的部分
这一锅涨得蛮快
66块一口气涨到110g
今天稍微有点拉回了
那拉回我们就开始观察
是不是有机会来做切入
先找支撑防守点
这边8月25号开始爆大量之后
做了一个震荡换手
后面又继续在工
代表说它有洗盘完成的机会
那洗盘完成拉回来
如果说能够守出那一天大量的低点
大概在97.3
不要去跌破
这个拉回回后
应该都还是有机会继续
再启动下一波公式的
好 很多人就是PCB动的时候
就会想到焊全
所以刚刚还理清一下说
到底要归类在哪里
就是板上面的连接器
没错 它是连接器
但是在板上面的连接器
好 那再来它这个重电骨的部分
这也是
对 这也是很久没动
但是最近川普对这个电力族群
好像特别有这个
罕金的动作一样
最近又放话了
要求什么
要求这地方未来电力设备
都要在美国在地生产
那如果说是在美国在地生产
我们就想到东源的部分
这个已经沉寂很久
但是它可能是最有优势
因为它在德州西乌厂区的部分
这是具有所谓
美国在地的一个优势在
所以它现在也积极
转型到AI电力服务人员的服务商
跟鴻海积极合作
锁定了包括辉达啦
微软这些一级的
CSP的供应链
所以股价的部分
是不是能够在
川普的推动之下
开始来做加温
最近300 400江大户
已经连续三个礼拜加码
那我们就可以去观察
8月13号
这里有一个带量长红
开始来做出现
那一天的低点
967.2
我们可以单位支撑防守点
未来不要去跌破
我觉得这地方
慢慢的股价就开始
有加温的机会了
好 等於在電力族群很大
有人可能像新生力比較活潑
接近全高
他是可以是積極型的代表
但有一些人是業績不錯
溫溫的在這邊等
其實今天講到美國製造
又讓我看到有一些新聞在討論
美國可能要科生半導體稅
什麼稅
這個議題並沒有完全結束的情況下
有美國在地製造
也有可能在接下來
還是一個蠻重要的關鍵
沒錯 可能到時候
又有新的題材出現
來追蹤這個美國在地生產的一個
相關的個股
好 非常谢谢献荣
谢谢
好 献荣真的不晓得
哪里来的灵感
他说股市看多了
你就会发现一些玄妙的规律
刚刚讲到外资的大买
也许它不见得每一个月都大买
可是开始买之后
通常会有一些微妙的变化
也配合着台币在升值
能不能拉出一波的涨势呢
听起来着实令人期待
但可以看的是个股
因为如果外资回头来补货
他们的营收又是高于一个平均值
甚至单元营收是高于年增率的
这样的情况
就是不断在成长的股票优先选
再来大户真的很爱电
那电已经有高高在上
比如像BBU快要创新高了
也有一些重电啦
这种电源供应器
还在这边直服在等的
都值得您留意
看您的风险属性是哪一种
好 今天非常谢谢三位的民意来到现场
今天是星期五
这个礼拜台股是公道的反贪高
但接下来我们可能类股要分开来看
看一下筹码看一下基本面
大家來決定下個禮拜自己布局的方向
那也希望今天理財檔案秀對您投資有幫助喔
下週再會了 掰掰